[Musique]
berné la boue
pas ces nouvelles instit nouveau départ
est ce que vous avez dit à punir des
lèvres qu'il avait rien fait alors qu'il
avait rien fait à bien son prénom à ça
tombe bien parce que j'ai pas fai
exercice comble les serres pour
aujourd'hui complètement marteau la
maîtrise il faut vraiment que tu arrêtes
faire des bêtises et une dernière chance
topo m'ont pas trop sera là tu te tient
à carreau
j'ai le plaisir de vous accueillir dans
ce nouveau lieu de culture
[Applaudissements]
alors ça j'aime bien ça c'est marrant
enfin il adore tous
il me faut un coupable mais c'est pas
moi on ne fait pas de bêtises dans un
musée soit complètement bien fait motos
à bas taux va pas aimer on est obligé de
mettre aux pensions l'enfant au pays et
l'enfant avance j'ai besoin d'un copain
intelligents ici je démonte pas mon
innocence je vais travailler en interne
au juge ahmed ezzobayry mec de toute ma
vie
non mais tu vois on s'habitue très vite
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as encore fabriquée
zéro plus zéro date et à toutes
bien et maintenant pour qu'on ne serait
pas un nouvel exercice ravis que tu aies
pu nous rejoindre sky j'arrive en retard
à mon enterrement
faites une liste des choses que vous
aimeriez faire je ne sais pas quoi
écrire écrire n'importe quoi les autres
s'en cogne ce bientôt tu vas mourir
tout va très bien kalfin ouais vous fait
quoi de mes symptômes vos problèmes de
santé ne sont pas physiques j'ai que
sortir un truc bizarre
crois qu'elle est trop bien pour moi
[Musique]
elle les trouve tous pour toi je
m'appelle easy sommes d'accord donc on
commence dès demain on commence quand on
analyse de truquer faire tout ce que
j'aimerais faire avant de mourir
[Musique]
c'est pas avec toi la vie heureux et
quand il disparaît tu me manques
c'est pas drôle ouais ben ali toussaint
c'est un jeu pour toi je vais mourir
alors tu veux que je fasse quoi que je
m'habitue à sur mon sort c'est déjà fait
ces examens n'ont rien donné tout ça ça
se passe dans sa tête
personne ne mérite de vivre ce que tu as
vécu mais au moins tu as la fille devant
toi alors faisant quelque chose ce que
tu veux
n'allez pas aussi forte au genou pas la
voir mourir
arrête de penser à toi pense à elles et
catus un ouais bah je suis en vie ni
trompette mais génial tu veux goûter mon
sens vite se relever un nom si on
récapitule thème pas mon sandwich rosbif
t'elle pas non plus ma musique
les gens qui se considère amis doivent
partager des choses telles qu on devrait
arrêter de l'être on devrait arrêter
d'être amis
alors qui fait exactement pareil on dit
et moi oui on pose comme ça tout le
monde le faire pessacais journée rhdp
donc fallu trouver
ouais faut croire qu'on n'a rien en
commun après il mange ton somain du paf
en maman elle a le droit d'être déprimé
merci elle retrouvera jamais un mec
aussi bien que nick
non mais sérieux d'où elle sort cette
[ __ ] de clarac personne commet après
il vient
marys comment ça se fait que j'aie
jamais entendu parler d'elle elle vient
d'emménager à los angeles et connais
personne ici donc tu t'es dit avant de
l'emmener au cha initiateurs jeu devrait
l'emmener voir le pénis de nick salut tu
es april et si on allait se voir déchu
tu comprends pas pourquoi mais aussi
gentil avec moi au moins ça nous
donnerait une bonne raison d'en coller
lune
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont pas déçus quand
ils essaient d'attraper la mission comme
s'il essayait d'ouvrir un focal de
confusion côté répété quand il compare
sa [ __ ] à une batte de khouildi il n'y a
pas encore fait ça avec moi
on devrait fixer des règles à notre
amitié
je suis d'accord
règle numéro un monde parle jamais de
nick numéro 2 on ne dit rien impliqué
tu vas pas tout cas fait une balance
benjamin tu sais ce qui leur arrive aux
balances ont laissé corse tout
sauvagement pendant qu'elle dorme on
désactive leurs détecteurs de fumée la
nuit en plein milieu d'un ensemble on
leur vole leurs crèmes solaires espèce
de tir aucun merde et bien sûr jolie le
meilleur ami relation avec sexe ont
toujours la priorité sur les relations
sans sexe dans ce cas elle et moi on va
te voir cuiseaux je pense être tout
temps
t'as pas assez fait preuve d'esprit
d'équipé note coupe
je couche avec personne tu dois juste
une fille c'est parce que vous croyez
[Musique]
vous l'avez trouvée oui s'il qui
pourrait cesser la commande alors ça
m'arrange pas des masses parce que gm
compte cool tu parles comme si tu avais
un vrai boulot eh ben j'ai un vrai
boulot ce graphiste
si j'étais toi je me méfierais de cette
manne basque
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce terrain
marguerite qu'elle ait obtenu marguerite
tout va bien avec madrid bab el manzeh à
l'écart nous sommes le 12 février 2020
extrêmement bon aucune malien poule
c'était la salle g ah ouais on a envie
de m'emmerder dépasse pas peur du
ridicule qu'on finira caire tu viens du
futur tu dois avoir des informations
fraîches et débarquement en normandie
la grande vadrouille rattrape les
habitants c'est comment de rentrer chez
moi là je peux pas te la péter parce
qu'on est au jeu tout en retenue
djamel au projet initié la magie église
[Musique]
c'est quoi ton vélo carole trop charles
bowden tuer ces étapes et à la réponse
est ce que tu veux je le fais rentrer
ouf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la nuit dernière
dayraut a été impliqué dans une rixe
touche 3 millions d'euros par an
j'aimerais que tu réalises que si on
fait de si gros chèque c'est pour que tu
t'entraînes est toujours pas long à ça
la vedette fait la une de tous les
journaux mettent toujours pour des
conneries
posté devant ta télé dimanche je vois
pas
vous voulez faire étudier ce footballeur
pour les faire passer son bac 1 sako
aussi vous voyez tu t'appelles autrement
sérieusement vous n'avez aucune idée de
caisse comme si tu suis pas le foot toi
edit à nico d'annuler les rendez vous
sur mes oreilles on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps
allez tout une touche toi
on a vu ça toute la journée je suis
débile
le voilà le problème
[Musique]
en fait j'ai fait une erreur de méthode
la première guerre mondiale
à ce stade là que fait l'allemagne
elle n'est pas contente rien n'est pas
contente c'est la première fois que je
reprends goût à mon travail
pourquoi je suis pas devenu fou de
bonheur
je voudrais te revoir en fait personne
en a rien à [ __ ] de ce gosse de quoi
tu as peur de me retrouver ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as bien dormi assez vite coco fermer
les yeux est entré dans le monde des
rêves
[Musique]
je dors ou bien je suis réveillé
techniquement tu es en train de dormir
dans sa chambre mais tu es l extérieur
de ton rêve
donc chaque personne a sa propre scène
sur laquelle vous contrôlez c'est ça
mais c'est une zone strictement
interdite à tous les rêveurs imaginer
que vos raid puisse se réaliser
ouah
mons ou de coco le cochon d'inde ont peu
changé les gens en agissant sur nos
pages il est vraiment trop mignon tu es
dans une montre ouailles à bhl aventures
gaffe regard tu rester hors de ton
plateau trop longtemps si on ne peut pas
te réveiller et bien
réveille toi maintenant je vais la
retrouver
ça risque de très mal finir j'avais tout
un projet cet été réaliser vos rêves les
plus fous dreams au cinéma le 5 août
l'océan un endroit d'une incomparable
beauté et en cette journée mondiale des
océans
nous célébrons cet immense écosystème où
vivent crustacés étoiles de mer blanche
céphalopode l'improbable écureuils marin
et bien sûr les bouches de mer j'adore
avis mais il nous à partir de nous unir
et le trait est vrai ce monde paisible
et délicat
[Musique]
alors pour la journée mondiale des
océans
à vous de jouer pour garder nos océans
propre et propre de l'habitat de bob
l'épongé
oups et de garrigue et de toutes ces
créatures marines vous ne manquez pas
bob l'eponge le film et pour jour de
troubles
[Musique]
12h42 l'inferno
du bonhomme est reléguée au caire
[Musique]
alors à sakharov en invoquant l'egypte
il comporte une aide unique et la radio
souriez bastos il va
kent displays sera zhaoxu
le thème
ceux qui n'ont pas de respect
[Musique]
ackermann au micro
mais saviez vous
comment
direct
ouais je demanderai à 60 ans
[Musique]
et si l'on suit ce secteur
c'est ça
plus que jamais
tout le monde
tournier